My oncologist told me that horrible blockers which are shrinking my breast tumors is killing the cancer.
I remember you say that that's not true. Your thoughts will know. No, I don't think the horrible
blockers are killing your cancer. So understand that that's just the way he's explaining it to you. So
what are bad estrogens doing to estrogen positive tumor? So bad estrogens are attaching to a
a receptor of the cell membrane of the cancer called the beta receptor of the cell membrane
of the cancer. The beta receptor is an apoptotic receptor. So it doesn't allow you're doing all this
other stuff to kill the cancer. You're using the right if you're doing all this nutrition,
you're stimulating your immune system, person might be doing keybalt therapy, etc.
Right? And if you are blocking the cell death of that breast tumor because you're not
reducing the estrogens well enough from a natural perspective or maybe you're not doing an
natural perspective at all, then it can keep the cell alive. So when you get rid of the bad estrogens
completely because you're getting rid of all your estrogens with a with a with a hormone
aerobatic inhibitor type drug, then you allow everything else that you are doing to kill the cancer,
to kill the cancer. So you allow that process to take place better. So I would say he's just
explaining it to you in a more simplistic to faction because you're smarter than that you're not
buying it. So